- Alright, we rolling?
We're rolling?
Let's do this.
Hey.
Hey Rodney!
- What's up?
- How's it going, Rodney?
- Yo, yo, good.
What's up?
- Question for ya,
are you free to be in a video right now?
- Yeah.
Like, what do you got?
- First question: how well
do you know your wife?
- I know her pretty well.
Been with her for like
three years, so pretty good.
- Congratulations.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you know your wife's bra size?
- Why?
Why do you want to know her bra size?
- Oh, I don't want to know her bra size,
I want to know if you do
because I want to see
if you can go shopping
right now for a bra for your wife
and then she'll try it on.
We'll see later how well you did.
- I mean, it would be kinda hard.
She's pregnant, she's
got bigger boobs now.
- Great, so you're
completely clueless about
what her actual breast size is.
- I don't know what's gonna happen.
- Fantastic.
Well, I want you to go right now.
This camera's gonna follow
you, so be free, Rodney.
- Oh.
- Go, go for it!
- Let's go.
- Bye!
Hope this works out.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- This is gonna be a little tricky.
My wife's pregnant,
her boobs are fluctuating a little bit,
and there's actually like--
this is kinda gross, but
milk is starting to come out
of them.
Where do I start?
We got the bras here, we found them.
This is like a bathing suit.
I don't know if I can
rock this for my wife.
Here's some bigger ones.
I'm not saying my wife is a big lady,
but her boobs are pretty big right now.
Okay, this is a C, and
this already looks ginormo.
I could do like a kind of visual,
like a flashback of my wife.
This flesh-colored one would be cool,
because she's just gonna
rock it around the house.
I don't know.
Is that what girls do when
they buy bras this color?
My wife's breasts are more full
and, I guess,
has more volume is a good word.
Hey!
This kinda looks good.
Little too big, but I feel
like this can be the guide.
Alright, let's go.
Lift, natural.
Is natural, I'm guessing, real boobs?
'Cause if you have big boobs,
you probably wouldn't
need a lift like natural.
Okay.
Invisible.
(sighs)
Just the terminology, there's so much.
Why?
These are like wings now.
I think this might be the one, though.
I think this right here,
a 40D,
I mean, this has to be the one.
Gonna be so good, so comfortable for her
big ol' milk jugs.
Where's a mirror?
Oh, here's a mirror right here.
Oh, yeah.
No one knows my wife better than me,
so we're gonna go with the 40D,
and we're bringing it home, alright?
Love you, babe.
You got this, this is all you.
(applause)
- So first reactions, how
do you feel about that?
- Uh, off.
- Off?
- Yeah, he's a bit off.
- We're gonna actually bring out the bra
that he picked for you to try right now.
Could we actually bring out
our entire rack of bras?
Please excuse the pun of a "rack of bras."
Right this way, set it right over here.
I believe...
(laughter)
Can we just have you try that on right now
over your clothes?
We'll see how well he did.
There's four clasps on there.
- That's intense.
- Maximum security.
(audience laughs)
- We can maybe put the baby in here.
- You are the ultimate
judge in this situation.
How do you think Rodney did in picking out
a bra for you?
- I'm happy it's too
big, and not too small.
He won.
- He won!
Give it up!
(applause)
- Thank you!
Woo!
- You guys can go ahead and head out.
Take care!
Say goodbye everybody, wave goodbye!